[Music]
what if one day machines decided that
humans were just a waste of resources
and with that in their artificial mind
started a robot apocalypse a robach
ellipse imagine the total revolt of
every automated device you use your
self-driving car refused to give you a
lift your iPhone X ignored your attempts
to unlock it with your face how bad
would this rise of the machines be after
robots take over would there be any
place for humans this is what if and
here's what would happen if there was a
robot apocalypse some robots can teach
themselves chess in a matter of hours
others run hotels and assist surgeons in
the operating room and hey look around
you we let robotic cleaners vacuum our
floors leave it up to litter robots to
take care of our pets and trust Amazon
echo and Google home to wake us up in
the morning what if one day our devices
decided that humans were redundant and
turned against us already picturing a
terminator like scenario don't give up
so fast there are many ways for you to
survive a robot apocalypse why not just
shut the door behind you
despite the fact that robots are
mastering math a closed door is an
obstacle that can't overcome yet well
most of them can't on top of that their
coordination isn't exactly perfect if
experimental bots in the robotic labs
went berserk they would just slam into
walls doors and any other obstructions
they meet on the way not so scary is it
what about our cellphones a phone's
options to harm you are very limited
posting that embarrassing video you
always meant to delete but never did is
the worst thing that they can do well
there's the possibility of them running
up huge credit card bills which one of
those scares you most there are
computers built into our cars but you
shouldn't worry about them if your car
was parked without a human at the wheel
it wouldn't know where to go anyway and
if you were on the road at the moment of
the robot rebellion you'd still be able
to control the steering wheel or pull
the handbrake
the biggest robots we have work in
factories assembling things but since
they're firmly bolted to the floor how
would they go about attacking us by
assembling even more things it doesn't
sound that scary does it
the real danger would come from battle
robots military drones floating high in
the sky at the moment of the robot
revolution would have no trouble
blasting missiles towards us luckily it
wouldn't take long until they ran out of
fuel and simply fell from the sky an
automated army of battle bots armed with
machine guns could cause major damage
though should we be afraid of nuclear
weapons computers are involved in every
step of launching the nukes but they
wouldn't be able to complete the task
without humans turning the keys even if
they managed to trick us into launching
nuclear bombs by feeding us false
information the robots themselves would
suffer from nuclear fallout just like us
nuclear explosions create a burst of
electromagnetic radiation
electromagnetic pulse or EMP it would
damage the delicate electronic circuits
of the robots and put an end to the
robot collapse
long story short a robot revolution
would come to an end pretty quickly no
matter how smart our devices seem to us
they don't have much in the way of
artificial intelligence they're
specifically designed to focus on a
narrow task and are luckily incapable of
destroying humanity but that doesn't
mean that Stephen Hawking and Elon Musk
were wrong to warn us about a future
super intelligent AI take over
we may be decades away from conscious
machines living among us but when we
manage to create machines that are
smarter and more efficient than us our
scenario will be very very different
what do you think would you give a
self-driving car total control of your
drive to work tomorrow
[Music]